you talked about the year-over-year
growth for your team and the additions
you've made one big one was Aaron Gordon
I'm wondering what do you feel he's
brought to your team since he's arrived
a couple years ago and his performance
tonight
maybe Mike can use for a discussion huh
pardon me I mean he's uh he's uh
you know he's playing a different role
and uh that's why he he he sacrificed
himself and that's why he's a great
teammate and that's why he won us the
game today you know I think if you if
you sacrifice yourself for something
bigger then uh than yourself or the team
or you know whatever so he's uh he
sacrificed himself and that's why I
think the The Wander upstairs gave him
the game today you know like uh gave him
today game that he had he wants the game
he was the he was our best player on the
floor and um you know guarding the best
player every night that's not a tough
job and maybe you're not gonna get a lot
of credit but we know what what he is
doing for our our team and uh we are
really thankful for him and appreciate
he pretty issued him a lot
standing on the back left
Mark Stallworth Miami Times Nicola uh
what were your thoughts on Bruce Brown's
performance uh he went to the University
of Miami here and what what does it mean
to you to have him on your team
yes of course uh he had uh he had an
amazing night and uh he was really
aggressive in the fourth quarter and
that's what that's what uh him and him
and Aaron were really really good I mean
they were they were amazing but he did a
step back three
I almost
I wanted to punch him but when he made
it I was so happy uh
and uh
you know he's the same the same as Aaron
you know he he's uh he's learning and he
is accepting and that's what the best
thing is uh about him he was he was
really good tonight aggressive you know
attacking and not being scared of the
moment
right here from UPI here um you
mentioned uh Aaron a little bit ago but
I'm curious with Aaron what's what's the
personal level of satisfaction for you
when you see Aaron step up and your
teammates step one up up and you're out
I know they're both wins but let's
compare that to when you get a triple
double and you lead your team to a win I
mean I always said I believe in my
teammates and uh did you know Aaron was
uh the best player in the problem in his
team back back in Orlando or one of the
best you know he had a completely
different role and like I said he
sacrificed himself that that telling a
lot of about him
[Music]
what was the question
I mean as long as we've been we I'm good
whatever